bonsoir jean marc rouillan nathalie
ménigon joëlle aubron
georges cipriani arrêté hier soir vers
21h sont considérés comme les chefs
historiques du mouvement terroriste
action directe cette arrestation groupe
et sans effusion de sang est un succès
pour la police tout entière et pas
seulement pour les hommes de l'unité
d'élite qui sont intervenus hier sur la
commune de vitry aux loges dans le
département du loiret les quatre
militants d'action directe se trouvait
dans une ferme isolée
voici avec emmanuel vanier jean
corneille et dominique thiel les
conditions reconstitué de l'opération
policière
voici la ferme où jean marc rouillan et
nathalie ménigon les deux chefs
historiques d'action directe
ainsi que joëlle aubron et georges
cipriani ont été arrêtés hier soir une
opération parfaitement menée par les
policiers du raid recherche assistance
intervention dissuasion avec à leur tête
le commissaire pange mancini il y à la
plus de 50 policiers du raid et 30
membres des renseignements généraux
hier dans la journée il cerne la ferme
et identifie formellement nathalie
ménigon à 20h55 l'assaut dans la ferme
la surprise est totale de membres
d'action directe tente de s'enfuir par
les fenêtres les policiers tirent en
l'air les quatre terroristes sont
arrêtés l'enquêté était en cours depuis
plusieurs semaines une prime d'un
million de francs avait été offerte à
tout informateur vendredi les policiers
recouper deux informations capitales
il mettait alors en place leur
dispositif autour de la plante des
terroristes lors de la perquisition les
policiers ont découvert un véritable
arsenal un fusil d'assaut 30 kg
d'explosif 80 détonateur et du matériel
des coûts très sophistiqué de nombreux
documents ont également été saisis
notamment des listes de personnalités à
enlever ou à tuer et surtout les
policiers ont découvert l'original de la
revendication de l'assassinât de georges
besse l'ancien président directeur
général de renault a battu en novembre
dernier à paris par deux femmes se
réclamant d'action directe
les policiers vont maintenant épluché
ses documents et analyser les armes et
les munitions
ils vont notamment les comparer aux
douilles retrouvées près du corps de
georges besse
dans la ferme six pièces l'une d'elles a
été aménagé en prison populaire les
enquêteurs pensent qu action directe
projetaient d'enlever prochainement une
personnalité importante dans le village
c'est la stupéfaction depuis trois ans
on connaissait bien rouillan et ménigon
qui se fait appeler nadine des voisins
tranquille est plutôt sympathique dit on
souvent qu'ils venaient ici trop fort
semaine presque trois semaines au
ravitaillement de chercher du lait mais
deux fois est venu pour rien faire mais
nous voulons dire bonjour et puis des
fois on a gardé la grammaire 80 elle
était sympathique vraiment gentille
vraiment hier dans ce petit village de
l'orléanais c'est donc une longue traque
de plus de 4 ans qui a pris fin